de 2022 quedará en la historia del día
que Roger Federer se despidió del tenis
O profesional lo hizo como deseaba
jugando un partido de dobles junto a su
rival y también buen amigo Rafaela Nadal
puede ser que esta vez está dupla
Federal como se les conoce no lograron
la victoria pero nos dieron momentos de
muchísima emoción Aquí en este harina en
la Londres que estuvo a reventar 20.000
personas vibraron en especial en este
super tybreak en el que fedal pues esa
dupla pasó muy cerca de la Victoria al
final de este partido hubo muchísimas
lágrimas lágrimas de felicidad Lágrimas
de tristeza también y sobre todo un
Roger Federer que casi no lograba hablar
de lo conmovido que se sentía pero que
mejor manera de poner fin a su carrera
que estando rodeado por sus seres
queridos estando rodeado también de sus
compañeros de equipo en esta
pero también rodeado Pues de aquellos de
aquellos buenos que ha tenido a lo largo
de estos 24 años y de también varios a
jugadores que lo han inspirado a lo
largo de su carrera por supuesto este es
su último partido un partido en el que
él hizo que se disfrutara de esa gracia
y esa elegancia que lo caracterizaron a
lo largo de su carrera pero lo cierto Es
que este es un fin de semana de un largo
Hasta luego porque está liverpoop
continúa hasta este domingo
y ahora sí vamos a hablar